V phương vinh, xuân sau trường tiểu học bỏ giá hất bà về tạm trự đồng một lấp để dây dời đều qua.
Thế bỏ người đất in những ngày qua trên tốc mật giá hội lãnh truyền thông tin và nánh về khoản thủ G phí dây và lấp biểu qua ở trường tiểu học mi đức thành phương vinh.
Trong cuộc khọt phủyng đồng đăng học ngày 18, trường tiểu học mi đức thông bảo một số khoản thủ,
trong đó của G phí dây dời và lấp biểu qua của tạm lắm từ vong học của sạm phòng học mới.
Tổng chi phí dây dây dây dây dây hoa ở mỗi lấp học là hất bà về tạm trự đồng.
Trong đó, chi phí dây dịch bà phà là bởi trăm mỗi viên nhàn đồng.
Tổng thảo bà chăm ngàn đồng về xí mốn chăm ngàn đồng, lắp tạm chăm ngàn đồng,
ổng đồng một chữ không chăm sóm viên nhàn đồng, ổn nước là một chăm ngàn đồng.
Chức bản kê gió nhà trường đo ra, nhiều phủ viên tổ ra không đồng tình,
cho rằng số tiền dây dây điều hoa như vậy là cao hơn sau với tị trường.
Mà ra việc dây điều hoa là là tự trức, nhà trường cũng không hỏi kênh phủ viên,
sau khi thực hiện sạm mỗi thông bà với phủ viên để được tiền.
Còn bạn, bản kể ghi phía này như thế nào.